about histamine, but before we go back into that a little bit, every question that I had
or both the questions involved, how do I get this test run and how do we find somebody
that could go over it?
Though there are a number of people that are as qualified or more qualified than myself
to go over this test with you, you just have to find them.
It's just up.
As I will explain, when you start talking about genetics, many practitioners will say, oh,
yes, we need to run the MTHF-R.
Have you heard of that before?
Right?
The MTHF-R is one gene.
It's actually two genes that were first research.
They have maybe more research, those two genes than others, but there are literally Facebook
groups, that are MTHF-R, Facebook groups, that are all about MTHF-R, like that is the
endol, beol, gene.
We haven't even mentioned that gene yet, and we are only a teeny little bit through this
and I'm never going to finish in this time, but so though the MTHF-R gene is important,
it's a gene in the folate pathway that we haven't gotten to yet, it is a small little fish
in a great big pond.
So there's a lot of practitioners that will just run the MTHF-R, and the patient, we
get patients literally calling us every week, or emailing me saying, hey, I have the MTHF-R
677, who was I, I guess, defect, oh my gosh, I'm going to die, okay, what are your other
genes?
It's so important to look at the big picture.
With anything at health, you have the farther you can stand back and look at the picture,
the better you're going to get.
You have to look at everything, so the more conclusive you can get, the better.
We don't want to put all our eggs in one basket, does that make sense?
So as much as I'm going to emphasize genetic testing, I'm going to emphasize that we look
at as many genes as possible, and genetic testing is not everything, it's just a piece
of the puzzle.
And like this practitioner or a patient, a pediatrician said, asked a question about the
gene defect that he had, and is this a significant defect or not, the research literally is coming
in on a daily basis on this stuff.
So as we get more research, we continue to add it to this profile, but just because you have
genetic defects doesn't mean you're doomed, and just because you don't have genetic defects
does not mean you're not going to have issues in that pathway.
So environment trumps everything.
So as we'll see that, though, if you decide to utilize my services in this, you have to
go to my website, and I have some slides on this at the end, but I don't know, I'll never
get to the bottom of that by slide presentation, but you go to my website, go to the genetic testing
tab, and you'll see a whole bunch more videos to help educate you on what genetic testing
is.
Again, you have to run the 23 and be first.
So if you want my help, we have to start with a case review, and that's done over the
phone or over Skype.
So I do genetic reviews for patients that aren't my full patients.
So they don't have cancer, they don't have live, or they're not coming to me for that, and
they just want a genetic review, they're getting treated for whatever thing that they have
going on with another practitioner, but that practitioner doesn't understand the genetics.
This is a lot of hours of educating yourself to learn this stuff, so don't abandon your
practitioner if they don't really know this stuff real well.
So we do genetic reviews for doctors, for patients of other doctors as well.
Those are all done over the phone.
Even if you lived across the street from my office, we still do genetic reviews over the
phone, so it doesn't make any difference where you live.
So we start with a case review, we call it consultation, or we call a case review, you're
just sitting in paperwork, we go over your case, that's about a half hour appointment, we're
talking to you going over your case, you run the 23 and me, you send me your user name
and password, this is all on our website, so I'll write this down, you send me your user
name and password, I pull off the wrong data, I send you what's called a SNIP report, SNIP
is a single nucleotide polymorphism, that's what these gene defects are.
And so I send you a SNIP report that's over 30 pages long and you'll go, oh my goodness,
we'll go over that though, and we set up a time that we go over that on the phone, okay,
and then from that SNIP report, I give recommendations, some dietary recommendations, and some nutritional
recommendations, like I said, some of these SNIPs, some of these defects are easier to support
from nutritional standpoint than others, so that makes sense.
So we have some patients, that's the easiest, that's the least expensive way to start
with me, if you wanted to be semi-appatient to mind, is just to do a genetic review, you
don't have to travel to Minnesota, we have patients from all over the world.
So all of it's done via Skype or telephone and email, and you get that information and
you walk through it.
So I can't give you recommendations based upon your cancer or your Lyme disease, or I can
only give you recommendations based upon your genetics, because I'm not doing an examination
on you, but you're going to see this makes a big difference, does that help?
All right, so now back to what we're talking about here, histamine is an important gene,
it's HNMT gene, like this person in this slide does not have a lot of HNMT gene defects,
but they still might have a lot of inflammation, systemic inflammation, even though they don't
have any defects in this pathway.
Why?
Because they have environmental things that are causing this inflammation.
Remember, histamine is a product of an immune response, histamine is made by your mast
cells, and in the presence of an antigen or an allergen, you're going to produce a lot
of histamine.
So when I have a allergy to pollen, I'm producing a lot of histamine, that's why I have the
symptoms.
Now, normally, if you don't have any HNMT gene defects, these genes should be working correctly,
should be making the enzyme that breaks down histamine, it gets it out of your tissue,
so you don't have, quote unquote, allergies, does that make sense?
But if you have a hyper exposure to an allergen, or you have an autoimmune disease, or you
have an antigen that's present constantly that you haven't identified nor gotten rid of,
you have this ramped up immune response that's firing all the time, so you have excess histamine.
So even in the presence of no genetic defects, you can still have a histamine problem.
Follow me?
So if the patient has symptoms of hyper inflammation, systemic inflammation, you want to look at,
from my perspective, I know, why, first, right?
Why does this person have systemic inflammation?
Do they have an autoimmune issue?
Do they have an immune system that's constantly turned on?
Do they have an antigen that's present?
Do they have HNMT gene defects?
Again, it's one piece of the puzzle.
If I have a patient that we're only doing a genetic consultation, and they have a whole
vote mode of defects here, they're going to have, most likely, have issues.
So systemic inflammation issues can range from, you know, headaches, chronic, I mean,
forward with a list of symptoms that buy a lot.
So I'm going to give you an example.
I had another father come with their young girl who had ADD, ADHD.
This kid was literally bouncing off the wall and I, that's kidding you, would I use that
phrase.
Already gluten-free, already dairy-free, we did a genetic test, we did a 23-amilum, this
child.
She had both, her HNMT, I think she had a defect at every one of these genes, but one.
And she also had multiple comp defects, which we're going to talk about, done the road, which
affects the neurotransmitter dopamine.
So she had excess dopamine because of the trop-defects, excess histidine.
So we put this child on a low histidine diet and we cut out proteins as well because proteins
are going to be the precursor for dopamine.
So we cut out the precursors for dopamine because they had excess dopamine and we cut out histidines
in the diet so that we would not continue to feed this cycle.
The parents called me several days later saying, we have a completely different child.
And she said, no, you don't understand, we've never seen her before like this.
She's a different human being.
I had a Tourette syndrome child.
That syndrome is where they get stopped blurring out expletives because they have excess dopamine
in the left frontal lobe, which is where your broken area is for speech.
And with that excess dopamine, it's a very excitatory neurotransmitter.
It just builds up and they just have to express something.
That child had a very similar genetic variant picture, did the exact same thing with them.
Cut way back on proteins, which are feeding the dopamine picture and cut out histidines.
The mother contacted us two days later, said that the Tourette's was down 80%.
And you could make a tremendous difference in a person knowing what their genetic picture
is.
Does that make sense?
So don't take this lightly, you can see dramatic changes in people.
So why would you, this is HNMT, which gets rid of histidine in the tissues, there's the pathway.
Histodine goes down several pathways.
This is a low histidine diet sheet that we use that is assuming people are a paleo diet already.
And we send this to people.
Things that are in the gray area are higher in histidine.
Those are the things you want to cut out to decrease or eliminate if it's really bad.
So anything that's aged has more histidine.
The histidines are in the gray area.
Eggs have histidine in them.
The more aged the eggs are, the more histidine they're going to have.
If you have your own check-ins in your eating fresh eggs, they have a lot less histidine.
Even leftover food has more histidine than it had yesterday.
So fermented foods that are so good for your gut, why are they so good for your gut?
Because they contain so many probiotics.
Also have a lot of histidine.
That's why I said, we can't use fermented foods with a person that's got a lot of HNMT and ABP1 defects.
Okay, so we have to use other things.
Does that make sense?
We also have to be careful with glutamine.
Because glutamine is very good to heal your small intestine.
A lot of products have glutamine in it, a lot of gut healing products have glutamine in it.
Our product that we created has glutamine in it.
But you want to stay underneath a grab of glutamine a day.
Especially if you have cancer, because glutamine can feed your cancer.
And some people that have a lot of bad defects that we'll talk about later,
and other glut defects, there's multiple glutamine genes.
You want to stay away from glutamine altogether.
Okay, still following me?
So I know it gets kind of complicated.
It does.
But it's complicated.
There's just no other way to put it.
You have to look at the big picture.
I just wish it was like, okay, just stop eating this and all your problems are going to go away.
It just doesn't work that way.
So you have to look at this puzzle of our body and look at it as a puzzle.
And there's a ton of different pieces.
And if you could get the majority of the pieces, you could see what the picture is.
The more pieces you could put in there, you could get a better idea of what the picture looks like.
Wherever it would be, 20 years old again.
We're always going to have degeneration.
There's no getting around that.
We live in a fallen world.
But the more pieces that you could put together,
you could get back to the level of health that you're comfortable with.
The next genes that we look at are genes that have to do with energy production.
It could be said that the biggest health complaint of people is lack of energy.
There's been studies that show that.
That's a common issue with my patients.
It's a very probably the most common issue with Lyme patients.
I don't have any energy.
I have fatigue.
So how do we make energy?
Well, you make energy through certain pathways in your cells, in your mitochondria of the cells,
that produce ATP.
So if you've heard me lecture before, I said you have several life goals that you didn't even know about.
One of them is to make ATP.
That's one of your life goals.
ATP is a little chemical compound that gives your cells energy to do different processes,
to run different functions, to push metabolic pathways,
and to give you energy to make you feel awake.
So ATP is essential.
There are genes that help you that make enzymes,
that help you absorb nutrients.
We talked about those, your FUT2 genes, etc.
So we need to look at that first.
That's why that's first on the list.
Are you getting your nutrients in your body?
Let's say we heal our gut.
We get rid of all inflammatory products.
We're eating a really good diet.
We stop eating junk food.
We're off of genetically modified garbage.
We get rid of the pesticides and herbicides and stuff with our diet.
We're at a low inflammatory diet or eating really good food.
We're taking really good nutrients.
Why am I not healthy?
Well, those nutrients circulate through your bloodstream.
They have to get inside the cells.
How do they get inside the cells?
These genes here.
So that's what we're looking at.
Because if we can't get those nutrients inside the cells and get them to create energy,
well, we're still toast.
It's not going to work, right?
So we make energy through the crebs cycle, through glycolysis, the crebs cycle, and
the acid chain and electron transport chain.
That's what these genes are.
These are your cartotene genes first.
There's a lot of genes in there.
Does this person have a lot of defects in those genes?
Fair about.
But you'll see people that have chronic Lyme have a whole mess of gene defects in there.
They can't even get the nutrients across the cell membrane to get them into the cell.
If you can't get the nutrients across the cell membrane to get them into the cell to get
them into the mitochondria, they're not going to work very well.
And here it brings up another point.
Some people will say, well, I have Lyme, and it's just disabled me.
I've had it for five years.
I can't even function anymore and lay it on the couch all the time, I lost my job.
But you're asking me to do a genetic picture that I was perfectly fine six years ago, and
I had the same genes.
Well, I've been doing this long enough that we're going to see certain patterns.
With really sick people, you're going to see certain patterns.
Matter of fact, we did a Lyme study that if we get through this presentation, it's at the
bottom of this presentation, where I can't remember 100 and some Lyme patients that went
through this study, and the familiarity that we had with specific gene defects with those
Lyme patients, these were all product Lyme patients, was really telling.
And I can see a genetic profile I've done this enough to look at it and go, wow, this
is a cancer patient, or wow, this is a typical Lyme patient.
Now, I'm not saying that a particular group of genetic defects is going to lead to Lyme,
Lyme is caused by a parentside organism, pathogenic, which you have to be exposed to.
However, the difference between Sally, who has debilitated with chronic Lyme for five years
and her next door neighbor, who that's pretend, got the same bite from the exact same tick,
the exact same virulence, both people started with the exact same health record up to that
point.
Let's pretend.
And the neighbor took two weeks of antibiotics and recovered and Sally still strongly
died after five years.
You really want to look at those two people's genetics.
So if they have genetic defects, in their mitochondrial pathways, and we're going over right here, they
have genetic defects in their gut pathways, if they have genetic defects in their SOD detoxification
pathways and stuff that will go over, they're going to have a more difficult time dealing with
a pathogenic that if somebody did not have those genetic defects.
To make sense, question.
So if you're having trouble getting your nutrients, can it affect your iron and your iron levels?
You're getting ahead of the game.
Yes, so there are genes that affect your iron ability to hold iron and holding too much
iron and iron oxidation, which is a whole other piece of the puzzle.
So one of the statistics with the Lyme patient group was that they have a tendency to iron
oxidation, that's down on the list here.
But yes, so their iron isn't even working in their body, so they have symptoms of anemia,
even having normal iron levels, or even high iron levels.
But the iron is oxidized, therefore it can't get into the cells correctly.
Still with me?
All right.
So here's some of these genes in this mitochondrial pathway.
This A-Cat gene is maybe one of the most important in this pathway.
So this person only has a couple of defects out there, but a lot of my Lyme patients have defects
throughout all those.
They can't make ATP very well.
And again, why are these genes when I was six today, I used to play T-ball and do everything
in a run-around, everything.
Yeah, it's amazing how your body can deal with defects.
Now you add an environmental insult on top of that and it's the straw that broke the
cymbals back.
Does that make sense?
Whoa, what happened there?
Whoops, hold on.
So these are other mitochondrial genes that you need to address what a person has fatigue.
And again, if I was dealing with a healthy person, these are your end-duff's genes, other
mitochondrial genes.
If I was dealing with a healthy person, they are doing a 23-in-B profile and let's say they
had a spathering of gene defects throughout this, like this person, right?
I would say, do you have fatigue?
And if the person goes, I don't have any fatigue, I can get up and go, I wake up and fight
for it in the morning, I go, go, go, go, I have to, my wife has to remind me to go to bed at
10.30.
Well then, I wouldn't support them, do you understand?
So in my mock, there are some genes, regardless of whether you have symptoms that you should
support.
And there are some genes that I would only support if the patient had symptoms.
So these mitochondrial genes, I would only support if the person had symptoms.
And I understand if I change that theory down the road, but that's poor event right now.
The FUT2 genes, I would tell that patient they need to support regardless of whether they
have symptoms.
Does that make sense?
Because you might not have any symptoms of your gut.
Remember, the only neurological fibers that you have in your gut are pain fibers for
distinctions.
So if you're not getting distinctions in your gut, you're not going to have symptoms.
But you're going to have all sorts of inflammation.
So I have FUT2 genes, I would definitely support them.
These mitochondrial genes, I wouldn't support unless the person had symptoms.
But they could be a telltale of why a person has this chronic fatigue.
So there's other things that are going on with chronic fatigue, not just the genes of
getting energy production out of the mitochondrial, right?
And that's how do we get into detoxification pathways that are so important.
These are more mitochondrial genes that we look at.
So there's a lot of genes to look at, right?
Detoxification with cancer and chronic life is essential.
So I said earlier that you really are what you absorb, you're not what you eat, you are
what you absorb, absorb, actually better is you are what you absorb, you are what you do
not detoxify, right?
So you absorb a lot of things, not just through your gut, but through your breathing or through
injections and things like that.
If you can get it out of your body, if it's not good for you, then it doesn't become a
part of you.
But if you can't get it out of your body through your detoxification pathways, then it doesn't
become a part of you.
So we don't want bad things becoming a part of us.
So you have specific detoxification pathways that's what I want to talk about.
Your first one is maybe one of your more important ones is your SOD pathway.
Here they're showing three, no, I think we have 13 in the pathway.
SOD gene makes super oxide dismutase.
Super oxide dismutase is a very important chemical in your body because what it does is it scavenges
a specific free radical, meaning that it goes and grabs onto this free radical super oxide
and it pulls it out of the body.
That's the whole purpose of super oxide disurface.
Very important because too many free radicals in our body could cause cancer, could cause
fatigue, could cause all sorts of symptoms.
So free radicals are bad, so I'm going to take a bunch of antioxidants.
Super oxide dismutase is an antioxidant that's made in your body.
It grabs onto super oxide and it turns it into hydrogen peroxide and then glutehyl,
which we'll talk about in a little bit, grabs onto that, along with caneles, turns it into
water and gets it out of the body and you urinate it out.
So your body is making super oxide iodine.
Ever I said before that everything is about balance?
You actually need free radicals in your body, what I said are free radicals are bad.
Well they are, if you got too many of them.
But not having free radicals is bad too.
You actually make super oxide through the botanity pathway but it's supposed to have a very
short life span.
So the half life of super oxide is very short.
Why?
Because you're supposed to have really healthy super oxide dismutase genes that make a bunch
of super oxide dismutase that get rid of it.
So it does its job, it helps kill pathogens and then your body gets rid of it.
So very important.
So if I have defects on my super oxide dismutase gene, I'm not making enough SOD.
So I can have excess amounts of super oxide ions.
Well that's not good because I can cause cancer, that can cause a lot of different things.
So the story gets even worse.
If I have a chronic infection like Lyme disease, then I have excess other chemical called inducible
nitric oxide synthase, sorry, it's really boring.
But this excess nitric oxide readily bonds to excess super oxide and it makes this really
nasty guy called proxy nitrate.
Proxy nitrate is extremely damaging to your endothelial cells, that's the cells that lie
in your blood vessels.
It's extremely damaging to all cells.
It can damage the cell membrane, even if I have really super healthy by the cudril genes
that we looked at just a second ago.
The proxy nitrate is damaging the cell membranes so those nutrients can't even get in.
Proxy nitrate in excess may be the merry cause of fibromyalgia type symptoms.
It is one of the principal causes of heart disease.
Heart disease is still the number one cause of death in the United States.
So proxy nitrate formation and controlling proxy nitrate formation is extremely important
that's why I said this SOD gene is really important.
Even if you don't have chronic Lyme, a lot of people die of heart disease on a daily basis.
They don't have chronic Lyme.
However, that's why chronic other some acute, some clinical eating not ever diagnosed infections
like each pylori are the cause of heart disease solely through this merry process.
I shouldn't say that.
There's another process that is involved too, but big part of it is through proxy nitrate formation.
Storing it's worse.
There's another gene called your NOSG that's in a pathway called your biopter and pathway.
And that NOSG is responsible for another type of nitric oxide synthase called endothelial
nitric oxide synthase and another one called derotol nitric oxide synthase.
That's for making nitric oxide into the brain for nitric oxide is actually a good guy.
In the brain for derotol tissue in the endothelial cells it's a very good guy, helps open up and
relax the smooth muscles in the endothelial cells, helps you decrease high blood pressure.
However, if you have superoxide, I'd float around, it's attaching it for a proxy nitrate.
If you have NOS defects, which we'll talk about in a little bit, you have uncoupled nitric oxide,
which can bond to superoxide.
So, I know it's a super felucated, I just lost half of you guys, but when you have SODG defects,
you have to support these whether you have symptoms or not, okay?
So, I don't have heart disease, I don't care, okay?
So, I don't have fibrobalgia, I don't care, you have SODG defects, we're going to support
this, because most people that have heart disease, how do they only have heart disease?
They died, okay?
So, it's not a good idea to wait on it.
Does that make sense?
So, this is an important pathway to support.
Here's the pathway, if you like chemistry, I love chemistry.
So, superoxide dissuades gene.
Every one of these genes needs different nutrients to push the gene pathway.
This needs copper, zinc, and bayonets to push this pathway.
So, one of the things, if I have a bunch of defects, I may want to use nutrients and help support
that.
Now, the beauty is, some of these genes, you cannot give end products, like if I have some
defects and the methanate pathways, so I'm not making enough sand, which we'll talk about
in a minute.
You can't just give it sand.
You can buy it in the store, but I don't recommend using it, but SOD does not work on a negative
feedback loop, so you can give a person straight SOD and catalyst in glutatholium to get rid
of it completely out of the body.
So, here's SOD, it takes superoxide, that guy right there, and it gets rid of it, turns
it into 100% peroxide, then this is the glutatholium cycle, it can't elase, it eventually turns
it into water, it gets it out of the body.
If you have excess, it excess nitric oxide, that's that HO, and takes this ODO, which is peroxide
nitrite.
Easy, easy, right?
Easy, easy.
You got this down, so we want to support that pathway if you have defects on that.
The glutatholium pathway comes from the bottom half of that picture that I just showed.
Glutatholium is one of the cells most important antioxidants.
If you don't make enough glutatholium, you're making all sorts of different things, so glutatholium
is essential to support this pathway as well.
Got a question?
So the NOS defects, so let's go back to our picture here.
If I have excess superoxide, that's by itself a free radical that can damage cells.
If I have excess free nitric oxide, which will come from a chronic infection, so if I have
a chronic, some clinical infection like H. Pylora, and I don't even know it, I'll have excess
nitric oxide.
If I have a known chronic infection like Lyme, I'll have excess nitric oxide.
You have a couple of those two problems together, SOD, GD, FX, plus excess nitric oxide, that's
how you produce excess peroxide nitrate.
You'll also get excess nitric oxide if you have NOS, GD, FX.
So you might not have any chronic infection, I don't have H. Pylora, I don't have Lyme,
but I have NOS defects, plus SODG defects, you have proxy nitrate formation.
So the NOS, GD, is in the biopteran cycle, that makes it the thelial nitric oxide, but if
I have defects of that, I will have a couple of these of that, it have excess nitric oxide,
flowed free flow of nitric oxide.
And any chronic, there's three types of nitric oxide, cytokine inducible nitric oxide,
which is going to be in a chronic infection, you're going to have ramped up that.
So any chronic infection is going to cause excess nitric oxide.
And then the endothelial, for the endothelial cells, and the neurotal.
So those three forms, glutathione is important, how to take that is important.
You don't always want to take just glutathione, it's not a really well absorbable.
And the new types of glutathione, as acetyl glutathione, are much better to be absorbed,
but typically, I don't even use that, we use glutathione support, because glutathione
was recycled, and if you support that recycling to glutathione, sometimes that's the best
way to do it.
It catalyzes the other gene that you want to look at.
So if you look at the whole gene picture, then you could go, wow, this person definitely
has problems with proxy nitrate, or whatever you're trying to correct with this person.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
So if you took liposomal glutathione, yeah, that's fine, that's another form of glutathione.
But again, we don't want to just, we have to be careful too, remember, too much of a
good thing, it's bad thing.
So we don't want to just push one pathway.
That's the danger of, oh, I had my MTA too far, and I am a positive defect on 6, 7, 7,
so I started taking 5 grams of folate in the methylcobalamyide, B12, is that a bad thing.
Yeah, probably, did you look at your biopterid pathway, because folate is going to heavily
push that, and if you have comp defects, I met people call and say, I would have folate
in methylcobalamyide, and I felt like I was going to kill somebody.
Yeah, because your dopamine and serotonin went through the rough, you'll see that as
we get to that.
You have to be careful with too much of anything that you think is a good thing.
Oh, glutathione, I read this book, I'm glutathione, so I'm going to take all this glutathione,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
These are all bit about pathways that are just literally flying, and you're just going
to feed one, it's going to throw things out, you have to be careful.
You're cytochrome P450 pathway, so now we're in, this is detoxification pathways, this
is mainly in your liver.
You're cytochrome P450 pathway is your main primary detox, what have you made, primary detox
pathways in your liver.
This person has, not to me only got enough defects in there, so again, how do we get rid
of poisons in our body through these pathways?
If these pathways are compromised, we're going to have issues.
This is an interesting, this specific ABP1 gene was researched.
This is how you get rid of donesteroidal anti-inflammatory drugs in your body.
Oh, I don't do good with Tylenol, I take Tylenol and I just feel sick.
Yeah, well, you probably have this gene defect, or as a doctor, I'm going to look at that
person's gene defect, so they don't have that, but let's say they have a 2 there, so
they have a double allele defect of that gene, or they're not going to prescribe those.
They don't get rid of them very well.
These are the people that take Advil, or take Tylenol, and they don't have a liver failure,
because they can't detoxify it.
Remember, you are what you don't detoxify, so if I have a patient that comes to me, says
I started with I have stage 4 cancer, and I did chemo, and I just absolutely crashed.
I can't handle it.
Okay, well, is it just because they emotionally can't handle it?
Well, maybe there's a component of emotions in this, but you have to look at their metabolic
pathways.
They probably couldn't handle it, because they have a whole bunch of cytochrome P450 pathway
defect, this defect, and pond pathway defect, we'll talk about a second.
They can't get rid of these chemicals very well.
So therefore, if you knew this before you decided to do some course of event, would it be a good
idea?
Hey, I can't do that drug because I don't get rid of it very well, or I need to do a much
lower dosage.
An aromatic medicine, these people are called monotypes, before we do anything about genetics.
People that can take one fifth the dosage of something, but that's all they can handle.
Because they can't handle anymore, well, most likely they have genetic defects in their
ability to get rid of it, and if you don't stem too high, you can hurt them, even with specific
new treats.
Okay?
So I've said before, one of the more difficult things that I have to do with a cancer patient
or a lying patient is divorce them from everything that they're currently tanking, this giant
londermask for the supplements that they have.
Too much of a good thing is a bad thing.
You take something and you absorb it, and your body can't use it, guess who has to detoxify
it?
You're a liver.
If you're overwhelming, you're liver detoxification pathways, even if they're perfectly
open, those things are going to stay in your body and they can negatively affect you.
So looking at your detoxification pathways can be extremely helpful.
Your pond one pathway is where you get rid of pesticides, insecticides, large chemicals.
What happened there?
Keep hitting buttons, what am I supposed to do?
Large chemicals and drugs, you get rid of the pond one pathway.
This person has a number of detox in there.
They don't get rid of those very well.
So this is where I say, you better not be sprayed, you're lond.
You better not be, you know, you better be sure you're eating the clean 15 and staying away
from the dirty dozen or buying those organic.
You better make sure you're not using insecticides and chemicals and fertilizers and all that garbage
in your house, you're better off making, everybody's better off making those decisions.
But definitely if you have compromise in your side of growth before 50 of your pond pathways
in the NAT pathways, I'm going to talk about it a little bit.
You really have to watch those things even more so.
And this is where you start getting into the question, do vaccinations cause autism?
Because I don't believe it, but my neighbor believes it, I don't really care what you believe.
But the truth is, vaccinations and the things that are in a vaccination have to be detoxed
through different pathways.
If you have a six-pound baby with pond one pathway, sign it from P450 pathways and MTHFR pathway
defects, you better believe they're going to cause problems.
You can't be saved enough that they're going to cause problems.
This child has no blind brain barrier, that's not formed yet.
So, you take a six-pound baby and you're going to inject all these adjabokes for this vaccination
into them and not knowing what their genetic pathways are, while you might as well just play Russian
or Latin.
So I tell parents, okay, you're going to have a kid, really good idea for you and your husband
to get it 23 and be done.
And then you can make it in for a decision regardless of what you believe whether vaccinations
work or not, we won't get into that because I can talk about that for five hours.
But if you know what your detoxification pathways are, you know what you're going to get rid
of them or not, okay?
So if the husband and the wife have a lot of defects in that, the chance of that kid is put
up a little graph, here's you, and you have a two, so a one or the one, your husband has
a one, they have a 50% chance of having a two, they have a 100% chance of having a one.
You want to take the chance?
Maybe a different way to achieve immunization would be better, all right?
Oh, I did the last line of that.
Your NAT pathways, your NAT pathways are a specific genetic pathway that you get rid of like
everyday toxins like cigarettes, smoke, and chart coal and everything that you're exposed
to that is just everywhere.
So you look at somebody who has a smoke, or I smoke three packs a day, do they have NAT pathways
that look like that?
Your chance of low cancer has gone up.
So if you know people, I know people, I've lived a hundred and five years old, they smoke
five packs a day, right?
Why?
Well they probably didn't have any of those G defects, yes.
So then you start asking the question, where did these defects come from, wasn't because
of the cigarettes smoke that caused that defect, right?
Very possibly.
So their children might have a higher likelihood of having that defect, yes.
So further studies down the road are going to take place in this, that's going to be interesting.
Yeah, they're happy genetic factors.
You guys still with me?
Yes.
So only about half the people in full of the sleep so far so that's good.
So they didn't get into the methylation pathway and this is what both doctors conserve
themselves with.
So we're going to do an empty HFR test on you because that's what a genetic test is and
we haven't even been going to talk about that halfway.
But this is the methylation pathway right here, if we looked at a chart.
Your body takes in full age, from full age, three leafy vegetables, goes through these different
genes that we have to look at.
It ultimately makes this thing right here, Bethol, Tetrahydrofolate, who's heard of
that?
A few people.
And methyl tetrahydrofolate that goes into the methaniety pathway and makes sand, that's
another life purpose that you have that you've got to know what about, and it goes into the
biopterate pathway to make all your neurotransmitters.
So your neurotransmitters, so it's very important.
So this following pathway is really important.
Methylation is the process of trying to run it off genes to make certain enzymes for the gene
to replicate, depending on what that gene does.
It has to be methylated and unethylated.
In order for that to turn it on and off.
So making methyl groups is very, very important for your body.
We have a deficiency of methyl tetrahydrofolate because of the dietary deficiency, which did occur
at the beginning of the first few decades of the last century.
The early 1800s, greedily vegetables, and we're not what city people were eating.
They were eating cakes and brands and things like that, right?
And they were eating whole wheat bread, they were eating white bread.
Now where do you get folate from?
If you have an deficiency in folate, you're going to have an deficiency in methyl tetrahydrofolate,
which is the active folate.
And what are the things that it could occur if a woman carried a baby has an deficiency?
It could cause a neural tube defect.
So women were eating any green leafy vegetables if you were a high class woman.
You're eating a lot of brands and you're certainly wording that brown bread.
You're eating white bread.
There is folate, greedily vegetables, there's also a little bit of folate in the wheat germ
of the whole of the wheat.
So that was stripped off to make white bread, there was no folate in white bread.
So people were grossly deficient in folate.
So babies were being bored with neural tube defects and when it was discovered that it was
folate, they created folate in the laboratory.
It's called folic acid.
So folic acid is synthetic folate.
Now if you look at the back of your vitamin capsule bottle and it says folic acid, and it
doesn't say anything else, it's synthetic folate.
Now it makes a folic acid as folate or folic acid as 5 metal tetrahedral folate or folic
acid as folate.
If it does that, then it's okay.
If it just says folic acid and nothing else or as folic acid, you should take that bottle
of vitamins and throw it in the waste basket.
Because synthetic folic acid will help prevent neural tube defects.
But it is theorized that synthetic folic acid is the cause of the defect that is so pushed
on the market of THFR and defect.
So epigenetically, it's thought that folic acid is the cause of methyl tetrahedral folate
defect.
It doesn't work with the say of this folate, you should not be taking folic acid.
So folate will turn into ethyl tetrahedral folate through this folate cycle.
And then it's used in several other metabolic pathways still with it.
This deep gene right down here, that MTHFR gene down at the bottom there is so highly regarded
because it was one of the first ones discovered and there's a lot of research on it.
There's two genes there in that family and that bubble there.
The 1298 gene made in stock that it mainly feeds the biopterant pathway to make neurotransmitters
and neuronal endothelial nitric oxide.
And the C67 gene feeds the majority of the cycle to make sand.
Which is your made methyl transfer group in your body to help turn genes on and off
and for everything to work.
So when I have a patient that comes to me that says why I have a homozygous defect on the C677
and C4 so it's going to die, you're not going to die and you probably shouldn't be taking
the whole mess of it.
And this is, I used to do this a little time ago too.
So we're going to put the person on, cause I used to be the only GUE for test.
So we're going to put the person on methyl tetrahedral folate.
Well the problem is that you push those pathways so rapidly if they have defects in those other
pathways you can cause a whole mess of symptoms, literally it can be a catastrophe.
If you make too much neurotransmitters you are going to have problems.
In the case of the two children that I mentioned that were patients, if they would have taken
either one of them would have taken, I don't remember if they were ever on it, would have
taken methyl tetrahedral folate or other methyl groups, they would have pushed dopamine production
very strongly.
These are the people that can become suicidal very rapidly or detrimental to society very
rapidly.
The excess of dopamine and excess serotonin are going to cause the very high levels of
aggression.
All right?
Still with me?
All right.
So these are the genes in that pathway.
We're not going to go over all of them.
They're all important.
And you see this person has an MTHFR-C677, a single allele or heterozygous defect there.
All right?
So now, making save.
So if I said ATP, making ATP is one of your life goals.
Making save is another life goal.
You need to make save.
If you don't make save, you're going to die.
And that's made in this methionine pathway.
So it starts right here coming from MTHFR through this MTR gene.
This is where you recycle B12.
This is the 4 Y to 4 of a B12 is really important in what you're taking.
We'll talk about that a little bit.
You get into methionine here.
And this is an amino acid that then converts to ultimately to sand.
Methionine is really important for cancer patients.
Because if we have MATG defects that converts methionine into sand, then we can have excess
methionine and cancer can feed off of methionine.
So this is where when we talk about cancer diets, and what are we going to put this cancer patient up?
Oh, well, the gerson protocol is going to put you on very high juicine and low meats,
which is technically similar to a low methionine diet.
So the gerson protocol would probably be very good for a person who has MATG defects
with excess methionine.
But if the person doesn't have MATG defects, they don't need to be in a low methionine diet.
Following, it's kind of confusing.
But the more information that you have and the more you know, the more valuable this can be to a patient.
Right?
And again, maybe for the average person who doesn't really have much room with them, this isn't all that important.
But when you're dealing with states or cancer patients, then light patients that can get better.
All this stuff is super, super important.
So looking at these pathways is really, is really important.
It's so important for you to make sand, which I've learned out on this picture right here,
because it's behind this little picture, that you make it through multiple pathways.
You make it through recycling, almost cysteine.
You make it through recycling, colline.
You make it through the MTHFR path that has to go through B12.
And this is why B12 is so important in your body.
But what form of B12 should I use?
It depends on what g defects that you have.
So most people that are going to go on B12, just go to the store and say how it needs a B12
and will buy B12 or go to a practitioner and just go on this B12.
It could be cyanocomalamine, which is not a good form of B12.
It could be methylcomalamine.
That's methyl groups, which you have to be really careful of,
because if you push too many methyl groups in a person,
and they have defects in their biopter and pathway,
which we haven't looked at yet, you'll push it really hard
and you'll make excess serotonin and excess dopamine.
So you can't do that.
So then you have to go to what other forms of B12,
a denticelacomalamine?
Yeah, that may be a good choice.
Hydroxychomalamine?
Yeah, that could be a good choice too.
So looking at the gene profile helps you to get specific
in how you're going to use supplementation for that person.
So how are we going to support that g defect?
Well, this is going to be probably the best choice for you to help push this the right way.
Hydroxy and a denticelacomalamine are safe for anyone.
Either one of those are, I would say, are safe for anyone.
Other than my shelf?
That's where I find them.
You can buy them. They're readily available.
Either one of those are readily available.
Hydroxychomalamine and a denticelacomalamine.
Yeah, I mean, maybe not in the normal cells,
which I don't know.
I don't even chop there.
Will methylchomalamine turn mercury stored in your tissues to gas?
I've never heard that. I've never seen any research on that.
But you do have to be careful with methyl groups,
because they're going to push different pathways.
So I'm not against methylchomalamine.
I use it all the time, understand?
It'll use folate all the time,
but you have to be careful looking at the whole big picture of the patient.
Okay?
And that is a key piece to overusing the supplement, too.
So if a thousand micrograms methylchomalamine is good,
that doesn't mean 5,000 is better.
That can be a lot worse.
And I hate to say it.
But these are metabolic pathways.
And there's different needs that you have,
depending on the stress of the day,
depending upon what you're going through from an emotional standpoint,
physical standpoint,
or no one could say,
oh, you need X amount of milligrams or micrograms of this nutrient
based upon your genetics,
based upon your organic acid test, based upon this,
it changes with the wind.
Now we do know that this might be a better supplement to take than this,
but you have to get a good idea
and how much you're supposed to take on that
and the balance of that,
depending on your stress level.
Yes?
Speaking of mercury,
do I have any thoughts on detox in mercury?
He's saying I have three minutes left.
So yes, I have a lot of thoughts on that.
But it's a complicated issue.
But we should talk about it.
But looking at those,
I need to throw P450 pathways,
because that's where mercury's detox is going to show compromise.
So you want to support those pathways.
So there are ways where I didn't talk about the detox pathway
to support those pathways.
So there are certain products that will push that pod pathway.
There are certain products that will push that site
or from P450 pathway.
And you want to support those pathways
if you have defects on those pathways.
This work gets to the gut again,
because your liver could be doing a wonderful job
in making these things water soluble,
dumping them into the kidney,
and you have kidney compromise
because you have urea cycle defects,
which we'll talk about later,
or dumping it into the colon
and because you have such horrible leaky gut,
you're absorbing it right away again.
Or because you're constipated
and you're absorbing it into your colon,
even if you don't have leaky gut.
So you have to deal with the gut,
you know, at the same time at least.
You can have a person be constipated.
This is where coffee intubus can help too.
So we put almost all of our cancer patients
on coffee intubus,
because that will help pull stuff out of the liver,
it will help the site grow before P450 pathways,
and it will keep the person from being constipated
a little bit too.
Okay, we do have to break.